AMY: Welcome everyone
who's just started
watching this broadcast.
And if you want to join in
person, feel free to do.
There are a few extra slots
left on the Hangout.
And there's a total of 10, so
if you try to join and can't
manage it, you can still just
watch the broadcast.
So let me introduce Proppy,
otherwise known as Johan,
who's an App Engine dev rel.
He's been doing a lot of work
with Go the language Go.
And this is Andrew, another
App Engine dev rel.
And this is Dave who
works on Go.
And my name's Amy.
And Proppy's going to give a
presentation about building Go
apps on App Engine.
And we want this to be as
interactive as possible, so we
encourage a few of you to join
the Hangout if you feel like
it and ask questions
as we go on.
And if you know the Go IRC
channel, I think someone's
monitoring the questions
on that as well.
ANDREW: And in the App Engine
IRC channel as well.
AMY: All right, great.
So let's get started.
JOHAN EUPHROSINE: So it's a
short presentation explaining
how to build a simple
application
with Go on App Engine.
You can follow the slide along
on proppy-go-ae.appspot.com.
So a bit of presentation
about me.
My name is Johan Euphrosine.
I am working at Google Zurich.
I'm a developer program engineer
on App Engine, which
means that I'm supporting
the App Engine Developer
Community--
on the forums, on stack
overflow, and also on IRC.
I write code for a new feature
when there is new SDK release.
And I write batch code
about best practices.
You can reach me through
my Google+ profile at
profiles.google.com/proppy.
And here is a photo of
me with more hair.
So what is App Engine?
So, quickly, App Engine allows
you to scale your web
applications by running them
on a Google infrastructure.
So you get to use the same back
end as Gmail, Calendar,
and other Google properties
exposed as API for your
application.
So recently, last year, we
announced the Go Runtime as
experimental.
So the Go Runtime has a few
unique properties compared to
other runtimes of App Engine,
which are Python and Java.
So each runs native code.
It has a very low memory
footprint, meaning that the Go
instance in App Engine usually
consumes less memory than
other instances.
It's also faster to start,
because since it's all
combined to a single binary,
when App Engine starts your
application, it only has
to read a single file.
Whereas with Java or Python,
that's [INAUDIBLE]
your application.
And also there is [INAUDIBLE]
for concurrency.
By default, what happens when
you deploy a Go application in
App Engine is that you spawn a
Go routine, which is like with
thread on each request.
And when one request is doing
some IO, it can process
another incoming request,
meaning that you get to
consume less instance-hour,
because your instance is more
used as there are more
requests coming in.
The runtime doesn't necessarily
need to spawn new
instances for a new
Go request.
So a really simple example
of how to write a web
application in Go.
So we just import
a few packages.
So we'll import the font package
for formatting string,
and the standard message to the
package, which order you
to configure with
an HTTP server.
There is an init function which
is called when Your
application starts.
And in this init function, we
just define a root to a URL,
which is called Hello.
And we map it to Handler, which
is a function of Hello.
And then in this function, which
takes two arguments, a
response writer to write our
response and an HTTP request
just to get the request writer,
we can write to the
response writer the
exit we want to
write into the program.
In order to deploy it to App
Engine, we need to create a
small manifest, which will
describe your application.
We named your application.
Its name is gopher.
We tell which runtime
we want to use.
We want to use Go.
We define some [INAUDIBLE]
for static files.
So if we want images
[INAUDIBLE]
by your application, which has
defined the best images that
we have, all the files
which are located in
the directory images.
Same for doc.
Then we just map all URL
to a Go application.
We can start an experiment with
the application locally
by starting the development
server, which is embedded in
the Go SDK.
And if we want to deploy it
to App Engine, we could
[INAUDIBLE]
that and we give it the best
application if we offer it to
App Engine.
AMY: I'm going to interrupt
for just a second to
encourage--
we saw a few open
Hangout slots.
So if anyone wants to ask any
questions, please do join.
And welcome to Marcel
who just joined in.
JOHAN EUPHROSINE: Welcome.
I've written a small
demo of the
application we've just created.
So it just prints a [INAUDIBLE]
string.
So now we'll try to do a bit
more complicated thing.
So I don't know if you are
reading the news like me, but
I always get it under checking
both Hacker News and
Programming Reddit
at the same time.
So we'll write a small
application that will allow us
to check both at the
same time without
opening two browser windows.
So what basically your
application will be doing is
that it will fetch the JSON and
XML stream of both Hacker
News and Programming Reddits and
print it to a screen and
serve it as a text file.
So, first, in order to be able
to fetch the Hacker News
stream, we'll import a module
which is called App Engine URL
Fetch, which allows you to reach
an API on App Engine
that allows us to fetch
remote HTTP resources.
We'll be importing encoding in
XML since Hacker News RSS feed
is encoded in XML.
And we define a new one there
which is called hackernews,
and we bind it to the
function hackernews.
And so here is how we can
decode XML in Go.
So you can see here the
structure of the RSS feed of
hackernews.
So there is a root element which
is called RSS, then a
tiny amount which is
called channel.
And for each item in this
channel, there is an
[INAUDIBLE], which is called
item with both a
title and a link back.
So we need to define
some type that will
map to this XML structure.
So to do that, we just define
plain structure in Go.
So the way you define structure
in Go is just that
you create a new type
declaration.
You give it a name.
And then you specify the main
door of your structure.
So here, for example, we've just
defined a structure for
the root elements.
And we said that a feed has
one data element, which is
called channel.
So here we have this small
annotation that allow to bind
or struct elements to the name
of the type in the XML stream.
So what is a feed data?
A feed data is a channel, so
it's a collection of XML item.
So here we just have
a slice of item.
And each item is a title which
is bound to the title type and
the URL, which is going to
the root [INAUDIBLE].
And so here we have no
hierarchy, a structure
hierarchy, which completely maps
to our RSS feed format.
And the way we decode that in Go
is quite simple, actually.
So we create a new function
which is called
hackernewsItem, Which will take
an App Engine context.
So an App Engine context is what
is necessary to issue App
Engine API code, and which are
the collection of items that
we use that we just defined
on the previous slide.
So we just create a new URL
fetch client, that will allow
us to make HTTP requests.
We issue a Get request to the
feed URL, which is having the
RSS feed for Hacker News.
We handle the error, so we
print an error in case we
don't manage to fetch
a stream.
When we issue a Get request,
we get a response back.
A response, we can read
the response with
the body number .
And we have to make sure we
close the body before our
function ends.
And for that in Go, we have a
very useful keyword, which is
called "defer," which will allow
you to specify function
codes to write that will
get executed when
your function exits.
So whatever exit form that you
have in your function, if you
return in the middle of your
function or if you just go
through the function
to the end, this
statement will get executed.
That line ensures that we close
the body before the
function exits.
And we create a new decoder
in order to decode
XML from the body.
We just [INAUDIBLE]
the root type that we defined on
the slide before, which is
a root element of the hierarchy
of the type for
defining the RSS feed.
And we call it the
Decode function.
And what the Decode function
will do is that it will pass
the XML stream and instantiate
an element.
The [INAUDIBLE] corresponds
correspond to the type that we
have given as an argument.
So when it will go on the
RSS [INAUDIBLE], it will
instantiate an HNFeed object.
And when you see a [INAUDIBLE],
it will
instantiate an HNFeedData
structure.
And when we see Item
[INAUDIBLE], it will
instantiate a new item object
for each item that's been
encountered.
And so after that, we just have
to return the data items
that we just passed.
And so the last thing that we
need to do is to print it back
to the both other issues
that we [INAUDIBLE].
So we just set Content-Type
to say it's plain text.
And we just iterate on the
objects that we get back from
the hackernews item function.
Here you can see how to
make [INAUDIBLE].
So there is a range keyword that
will return both an index
and an item for each item that
we get back from the
hackernews item function
[INAUDIBLE], which we just
print each item title
and each item year.
So here we can see
a little demo.
all the links.
So this tells the URL of each
item that is in the Hacker
News RSS feed.
So there's does anyone
have any questions?
ANDREW: Proppy?
JOHAN EUPHROSINE: Yeah.
ANDREW: On the previous slide,
what was the underscore in
that range statement?
JOHAN EUPHROSINE: Ah.
So good question, Andrew.
So the underscore is to
say that we don't
want to use this parameter.
So it just binds
the parameter--
since we have to explicitly say
that we want to enter this
[INAUDIBLE].
So as a range keyword,
we return two
items for each duration.
We have to say that we don't
want to enter this parameter.
So we just-- the [INAUDIBLE],
we say that we don't want to
enter this parameter.
ANDREW: So if I did have a
variable there, it would be
assigned the index page?
JOHAN EUPHROSINE: Yeah.
So the range would return both
each index and each element of
the collection that
is on the right.
AMY: So I have a question
for you, Proppy.
This code all looks
pretty clean.
With what you've shown so far,
what about it do you think is
maybe easier than writing
in Python?
Or what maybe is harder?
How would you like to comment
on that, or would you maybe
want to wait until you show
a little more code?
ANDREW: I don't think he's
gotten to the good part yet.
AMY: OK.
JOHAN EUPHROSINE: Yeah, that's
an interesting question.
So in Python you have some
legends that you need to
decode XML on the fly and
map it to objects.
That's usually-- what you
get back from that is a
dictionary, because
you can't--
they only generate tags that
Python could use without
knowing it, without knowing what
you want to decode, is
just a plain dictionary.
And so the type of [INAUDIBLE]
that you've got the same
convenience as Python for
decoding arbitrary XML
structure that you also get
access to because you define
exactly what you
want to decode.
And it's not two concrete types
that you have defined in
your application.
Whereas in Python, what you
will get, we'll see now.
It will not be more complicated,
but it will be
less [INAUDIBLE].
Because what you will get back
from a general decoder XML
function will be just
a Python dictionary.
Whereas in Go, you get proven
types that you have defined.
ANDREW: So does that mean that
when you're using the Python
dictionary you would need to
test for the presence of
various keys?
Whereas in Go, the data types,
because the fields are always
present in values of those
types, you don't
need to do all that?
JOHAN EUPHROSINE: Basically,
it allows you to address
[INAUDIBLE] or XML and be sure
that they are there.
Whereas in Python, you are not
sure what is in the dictionary
[INAUDIBLE].
AMY: Just as a Go novice,
that's one thing
I like about it.
The strict typing, but the easy
definition, so it doesn't
have all the syntactic
overhead of
something like Java.
JOHAN EUPHROSINE: I think it's
very [INAUDIBLE] that you
could pass an XML that's in your
line and just annotate
your type just with simple
annotation binding a field, a
strict field to XML.
There is no syntax you could
write for something which is
not triggered.
I mean, like data binding is
not a triggered operation.
I find the solution that Go
uses is very convenient.
ANDREW: There's also one other
nice thing about it, which is
that the XML decoder will only
decode and store those fields
that you actually have present
in your Go data type.
So if you're decoding a really
large XML stream, you won't
have to load all that stuff
into memory before
discarding it again.
You can just only take out the
fields you're actually
interested in.
JOHAN EUPHROSINE: Yeah.
Whereas when you write for
Python, generally the Decode
function will decode
all the fields.
You will have to manually
write to--
I mean, either you do the
parsing yourself using some
kind of reader and then you can
selectively get what you
want, but then your parsing
for this doubles.
Or if you use a generic decode
function, you would just get
an enormous [INAUDIBLE] if you
have an enormous string.
AMY: As Andrew said, I suspect
you're getting to the really
cool stuff in just
a minute here.
JOHAN EUPHROSINE: Actually,
just the same with JSON,
though we do exactly the same
with Programming Reddits.
And so Reddits APIs
have a JSON file.
And actually, it's both an
access file and some JSON
file, but the RSS file structure
is quite messed up.
So you can't access the link of
the element, because it's
encoded to see that inside
the description.
So for being able to easily
pass title and links
programmatically of Programming
Reddits, you need
to use the JSON API.
For that, we'll just import
encoding JSON, just like we
imported encoding XML before.
We'll define a new Handle, which
is called "proggit."
There is a URL slash proggit.
And we'll map JSON to Go
type, just like we've
done before with XML.
So the structure of the JSON
feed is a bit complicated for
what it is.
But it's like this.
So you've got the data element,
which has a children
attribute, with a collection
of children element.
Each of these trigger an element
also of the data
attributes, which finally
adds a title and a URL.
And so we'll just define
Go type just as before.
So the range field is
a data element.
And so you see here that we
don't have any annotation
because what I find in Go is
that if you don't define an
annotation, the decode function
will default on
passing the attributes
that correspond to
your property name.
So clearly we know that it needs
to get better attributes
because we've defined a property
in your structure
which is named data.
So a Reddit feed data is
a collection of items.
And so we have a Reddits feed
item type, which will match to
the JSON children attributes.
And so here, you can see that
we have put an annotation,
because the name of our property
is different from the
name of the attribute.
And then each Reddit feed thing
will be a data item here
just to capture what is
in the attribute data.
And the item structure will
just be the same structure
that we have been using before
for the [INAUDIBLE].
So here we see that we are two
hierarchy types that shows the
same leaf type elements
which is item.
So we'll be about to decode
Hacker News and Programming
Reddits using two different
functions, and we will get the
same item types back from
the Go function.
So here, that is how we
get [INAUDIBLE] on
JSON streaming Go.
So it's quite similar to what
we've seen before with XML.
The only difference is that we
instantiate a new JSON decoder
instead of instantiating
an XML decoder.
We use a Reddit feed type
instead of using the Hacker
News feed type.
We can decode.
In order to return
a collection of
item, we have to--
it writes--
because what we get back from
the decode function is a
Reddit field, which is a Reddit
feed data, which is a
collection of Reddit
feed item.
And what our function returns
is a collection of item.
So we need to instantiate
a collection of item.
So you do that in Go by using
the Make key word, which
allows you to instantiate
a slice of item.
And you can specify a LAN,
events, and the capacity.
You know we know the LANs in
advance, so we can say that we
want to instantiate as many
items that we have--
Reddit feed item, you know,
in the Reddit feed data.
And so we just integrate an
old item and fill the new
slide that we have
just created.
And so in the end, we
get a slice of item
back from this function.
What's left is just that
we need to print it.
So as before, we just set the
Content-Type and iterate from
what we get back from the
proggit item function and
point it to the response.
So here you can see that we
just printed the top items
that are in Programming
Reddits--
the title and the URL
on the right.
AMY: And Proppy?
JOHAN EUPHROSINE: Yeah?
AMY: Since people might not be
able to see that output very
well and just might be
interested in general, I think
that you have the code
also on code.google
somewhere, don't you?
JOHAN EUPHROSINE: Yeah, at the
end of the presentation, there
will be a link to the code.
AMY: OK, great.
JOHAN EUPHROSINE: So now we need
to print both, because we
are printing Hacker News items,
Programming Reddit item.
And now we want to print
both on the response.
And so since we can just call
our hackernews item function,
call our Programming Reddits
item function, get the item
back, And just iterate
on each of them and
print them in the response.
And so we'll first print the
Hacker News item, and then
print the Programming
Reddit item.
And here we can see that we
actually printed both.
And you can see, I added some
[INAUDIBLE] statement in the
code before in order to
check the latency.
So we see that it took like 260
milliseconds to fetch the
item from Hacker News.
It took like 100 milliseconds
to fetch
the item from proggit.
To print both of them--, like
the latency of the [INAUDIBLE]
function, which was Progginator,
it's just the
same as the latency of Hacker
News and proggit.
So it means that if I can use a
slow, like we won't be able
to print anything before
I can use it as Handle.
And also, we'll just send it to
latency of both URL fetch.
And so what we need to do now
to be more efficient is to
make it concurrent.
So it's just like the same code
that we've seen before,
we just added a few keywords.
So we are using the Go
[INAUDIBLE], which is from the
goroutine, which is
the [INAUDIBLE].
It will allow us to fetch
a Hacker News item and a
Programming Reddit item
concurrently.
So here we just--
in order to get the item back
from this goroutine, we'll
create a channel.
So we create a channel.
A channel is a structure that
will allows goroutines to
communicate safely
between them.
So you first just figure out Go
tied to a channel, and you
can send the item to a channel
and read item back.
And what we will do, being that
we spoke to goroutine,
that we'll each send a slice
of item to the channel.
In the parent goroutine that
has been spawned to
[INAUDIBLE] request,
we just [INAUDIBLE]
back from the channel.
So it means that both
UR shell [INAUDIBLE]
fetch concurrently
has happened.
So here we just create a new
chain on which [INAUDIBLE].
Here we spawn the goroutine and
send the wizard, which is
a slice of item back
to the channel.
Here we spawn another goroutine
for Programming
Reddits and send the wizard
back to the channel
Here we iterate.
We do an iteration of two,
because we have two
[INAUDIBLE] to read
from the channel.
Read them.
So this is a syntax
for receiving
stuff from the channel.
And then we iterate up each on
the slice we get back from the
channel and print them
to the screen.
And here you can see exactly
the same [INAUDIBLE]
as before.
And notice it's just
quicker, because
here are the latencies.
So Programming Reddit takes
like [INAUDIBLE]
seconds.
Hackernews takes 190 seconds.
The progginator function
only takes the highest
latencies of the two.
So it means that both of
our fetch calls happen
concurrently.
Since they happen concurrently,
we are only
bound to the slowest one instead
of being bound to the
center of the two latencies.
So are some takeaways
from the talk.
The encoding package makes
parsing fun again.
So we see that it's really easy
to bind a Go native type
to either XML ends or Java
attributes, which make parsing
really easy and serve a call.
We have seen the Go runtime
is inherently concurrent.
So you can easily spawn a
goroutine and make sure to
handle any operation
concurrently.
And also, the Go runtime will
run a Go routine each incoming
HTTP request.
And we've seen also that
there is no need--
in Python and in Java, in order
to do the [INAUDIBLE],
we'd have to use an async API.
Here we see that in Go, we don't
need to add an async and
sync version of an API.
We just wrap the code we want to
be in sync with [INAUDIBLE]
and just use a channel to get
the [INAUDIBLE] back and
return a synchronous API code
into something asynchronous.
And so there is some homework
that you can do in order to
improve this demo.
Obviously, the same stuff
gets often [INAUDIBLE]
since you've got
both hackernews
and Programming Reddits.
So you can write some
code to get
duplicates and also by ranking.
You can make it pretty, because
it's just plain text
right now, so you can make
it prettier with
templates and CSS.
You can move the fetch to happen
offline instead of
happening on each
user request.
So instead of doing a URL fetch
on each HTTP request,
you can [INAUDIBLE]
that will do the URL fetch as
a bad one and then cache it.
So when you have like thousands
of people that use
the site, you don't do a URL
fetch to fetch some content to
Reddit and [INAUDIBLE]
each time.
And you can go fork the messy
code at this URL.
So
code.google.com/p/progginator project.
And the slides are also
available in this [INAUDIBLE]
too.
So thank you.
There are some links that you
can investigate if you want to
work further.
This is a doc for the Go
App Engine runtime.
This is the main website
for the Go [INAUDIBLE].
And there is my profile
on Google+.
So if you have questions,
we can do them now.
AUDIENCE: Proppy,
can you hear me?
JOHAN EUPHROSINE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Just a
quick question.
You were using [INAUDIBLE]
channel [INAUDIBLE]
when you're collecting
the item [INAUDIBLE]
concurrently.
You would be passing directly
the channel [INAUDIBLE].
passing them to your template.
JOHAN EUPHROSINE: I'm sorry--
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
JOHAN EUPHROSINE: [INAUDIBLE].
I couldn't really hear
the question.
Can you try it a little
bit more slowly?
[INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: I'm in the chat.
JOHAN EUPHROSINE: Yeah, just
type through the chat.
It would be simpler.
AMY: Yeah, I can read
it out if you like.
[TYPING]
JOHAN EUPHROSINE: So the
question is, if you were using
templates, would you patch them
directly to the templates
or collect an item and pass
in those to the templates?
So I think I would
do the latter.
So what I would do
is that I would--
because what I get back from
the channel is not actually
the usual item.
I get a slice of item
from the channel.
So what I would do is with the
main Go routine, I would
collect the item from the
channel, the slice of item
from the channel, and just print
them out by template by
giving it the slice of
item [INAUDIBLE].
That's really [INAUDIBLE]
different perspective of this.
ANDREW: With the way it's
currently designed, then,
yeah, you probably
would do that.
But it is possible from within
a template to range over a
channel in the same way that you
can range over a channel
in novel Go code.
And that's particularly useful
if you have some code that's
generating values, like a large
stream of them, and then
you want to generate a
particularly large template.
You can have your generator
and your template being--
you have the values being
generated and the template
being constructed concurrently
without having to load your
entire data into memory, which
is a really nice property.
But in this particular instance,
you're already
loading all of the items into
memory immediately when you do
the JSON and XML decodes.
So there's no real advantage
to streaming them into the
into the template itself.
You might as well just collect
them, and arrange them before
passing them into
the template.
And that's what I would
do usually as well.
JOHAN EUPHROSINE: Also when we
pass an item, a slice in the
channel it's not-- it doesn't
copy them [INAUDIBLE].
It's just a reference to the
same slice of this, right?
ANDREW: Yep.
JOHAN EUPHROSINE: So we aren't
duplicating the slice content
in multiple goroutines.
ANDREW: I was going to say, in
this case, are they items, are
they values, or are they
pointers to items?
It looks like they're
items themselves.
JOHAN EUPHROSINE: Yeah, they're
items themselves, but
when you pass it to a channel my
understanding is that when
you enter a slice of item to a
channel, you don't copy the
individual elements, right?
ANDREW: Yes, that's correct.
I mean, when you pass a slice
around, you're passing a
reference to the underlying
data.
But if you wanted to sort or
de-duplicate those items and
interleaf the ones from proggit
and the ones from
Hacker News together, then
you might consider
using a pointer type.
So a slice of pointers to items
instead of a slice of
items, and you'd have some
small saving there.
But the actual item struct
is very small, because it
consists of some
string values.
And string values in Go are
reference types as well.
And so there's very little
copying going on there.
I mean, each item
is probably only
about 64 bytes or something.
JOHAN EUPHROSINE: So very
quickly, take a look if
there's any questions on Google+
or on the [INAUDIBLE].
AMY: OK, I have a question for
you, Proppy, if there are no
other questions.
I have to take a quick
look first.
ANDREW: Well, there is one
question on the moderator,
which is an App Engine
question.
And it's from Jurka Danyik
from the Czech Republic
saying, I don't want my app to
depend on App Engine too much.
I'm afraid of the vendor
locking issue.
How hard is it to build an app
in Go that runs on App Engine,
and if needed, can be moved
to my private web server?
JOHAN EUPHROSINE: I think that
actually David can comment
about this, because he recently
implemented something
in the Go build that
dealt with it.
DAVE: It'd be pretty easy to
write a Go App Engine app that
has minimal dependencies
on App Engine itself.
For example, the Go website
itself, golang.org, is built
by an App Engine app.
But that App Engine app is
almost completely just Go doc,
which is a standard Go program
that you can build and compile
and run on your own machine and
ships with the standard Go
distribution.
All that has is a very small,
little [INAUDIBLE]
file that [INAUDIBLE].
And other than that, it's just
a regular, like I said,
[INAUDIBLE] design.
The Go runtime on App Engine
is pretty permissive for
allowing you to write something
that's independent
of App Engine.
ANDREW: So to learn to write
an app like this, this is
actually very portable, because
the HTTP package is
well integrated with
Go on App Engine.
So like what Dave just said, if
you write just a straight
web app that doesn't really talk
to much of [INAUDIBLE],
you can basically just use one
in one place or the other.
The one that we're using
here is URL fetch.
And if you look at the--
is it on this slide?
Proppy, can you go to a slide
which has the [INAUDIBLE]
urlfetch client on it.
I think that had it.
So if you notice on the first
line of this function after
the declaration, the URL fetch
client, that variable client
is actually just an HTTP client,
the same type of HTTP
client you would use in a
standalone Go program as well.
So the URL fetch client just
implements the same
interfaces.
And you can use anything that
expects those interfaces,
which is basically any Go
package that uses HTTP.
So we tried really hard in
creating all of the Go App
Engine APIs to use a lot of the
standard Go interfaces so
that it's really easy to--
I use the Go standard library
and external libraries with
the App Engine APIs and also to
decouple your app entirely
from App Engine.
With that said, if you write an
App Engine app that depends
heavily on the task
infrastructure and the App
Engine data store, those are
really, really rich APIs.
And that's one of the real value
adds of the App Engine
platform, is that you get these
really, really scalable,
reliable systems.
That you don't get free.
And it would be a little bit
more difficult to divorce
yourself from that.
JOHAN EUPHROSINE: It's
interesting to note that there
is a project called App Appscale
that implements the
Go runtime.
It allows you to run basically
APIs tablet that [INAUDIBLE]
database or [INAUDIBLE] software
that will just
provide you the same SPI that
you have on App Engine, just
with different back-end
issues, like MongoDB,
[INAUDIBLE].
And also I wanted to--
maybe David can you tell us a
bit about the build tag, the
App Engine build tag.
Because I think that you can
easily design your apps so you
have the App Engine specific
parts that are as efficient as
with App Engine buildout.
And so you can still use the
regular Go build to build your
stuff without the App Engine
specifics, right?
DAVE: I'm not entirely sure
what you're asking me.
[INAUDIBLE]
that you fill in with an
implementation that you're
using the App Engine
APIs and--
JOHAN EUPHROSINE: No, I was
thinking like, for example,
Andrew was saying that your URL
fetch module uses the same
JFS as the regular
HTTP client.
DAVE: Yeah, [INAUDIBLE].
JOHAN EUPHROSINE: If you write
your App Engine specific code
and just [INAUDIBLE]
it with the App Engine name tag,
can you make sure that
the Go To when it builds your
application doesn't build the
pieces specific to App Engine?
DAVE: Yeah.
So just in the same way as you
could say some platform
depended on [INAUDIBLE] or that
you had some who would
only work on Linux or some who
will only work on Mac or some
who would only work on Windows,
you can add a little
annotation at the top of your
source files, and then Go To
will only build those when
it's on that platform.
The same thing with
App Engine.
So if you have a build tag at
the top of your file that says
this file requires App Engine
or App Engine apps
[INAUDIBLE].
JOHAN EUPHROSINE: OK, so yeah, I
think that's neat that there
is a super build team into the
Go To number to get one
application that can get
more than one platform.
DAVE: Yeah.
AMY: So let me ask you
a question, Proppy.
And this is also directed to
Andrew and Dave, if you want
to answer it.
So the Go routines and channels
are really cool.
And it's sort of a philosophical
departure from
what people might be used to
or might think of as your
regular thread program if you're
a Java programmer.
And it seems like it lends
itself less to getting into
trouble with that kind
of programming.
Maybe you want to comment
a little more on that?
ANDREW: Well, I mean, if you
consider Proppy's example of
performing these two calls in
parallel and then having a
rendezvous and collecting the
results, using a traditional
kind of semaphore approach, you
would probably use a white
group or something like that.
Generally, there's just a lot
more boilerplate involved in
setting up the channels and
setting up the locks.
And then there can
be a lot more--
basically what you're
doing is you're
talking around the problem.
You're creating these
kind of [INAUDIBLE].
JOHAN EUPHROSINE: So it seems
they are just frozen for me.
Is it the same for--
OK, so you were frozen.
AMY: Yeah, we're back, but I
think we need to start over
with what Andrew was saying.
ANDREW: In essence what I'm
saying is that in Go, to make
something run another thread
is [INAUDIBLE]
in the space.
In pretty much any other
traditional threading
environment, there's a
lot more involved in
setting up a thread.
And similarly, to communicate
between threads in the
traditional method, you
have some sort of
semaphore, like a lock.
And then you have the data that
you want to communicate,
and they're two separate
things.
In Go they're combined
into the same thing.
You have a channel, and the
channel is both a signal--
it's synchronization--
and it is the message itself.
It's the data.
And so it's a lot less error
prone, particularly once the
system becomes more complex.
And so I think it's a pretty
clear win, if you're doing any
kind of [INAUDIBLE] software.
JOHAN EUPHROSINE: One of the
mantras of the Go [INAUDIBLE]
is don't communicate by
sharing, but share by
communicating.
I think that it's fitting.
It's also really useful.
I mean, the way the App Engine--
maybe David can
correct me, but the way that App
Engine runtime is designed
is that it will spawn one Go
routine for each information
you request.
It will not run more than one
Go Looking at a time.
But if one Go looking is doing
IO, it can add an addition to
another Go To.
And since most of what App
Engine apps are doing is to
make APC code and API code,
that's really a strong win for
App Engine.
Even if it's single threaded,
it's on [INAUDIBLE]
operation concurrently.
ANDREW: And Go is easily the
most lightweight of the three
App Engine runtimes as well.
So in terms of squeezing CPU
time out of your instances, I
think it's pretty good
for that, too.
Does anybody else that's in
the Hangout have questions
that they'd like to ask about
the talk or about App Engine
or about Go?
AMY: Are you still on
the IRC channel?
JOHAN EUPHROSINE: Yeah, I've
muted a few people, so maybe I
can unmute them.
And so does anybody
have a question?
No?
AMY: There's Chris.
JOHAN EUPHROSINE: Oh,
Chris is here.
Hey, Chris.
AMY: Any questions about
[INAUDIBLE]?
JOHAN EUPHROSINE: I do.
DAVE: Does the mic work?
JOHAN EUPHROSINE: His
mic is broken.
So he may have a question
on chat.
He says, I like the example
where multiple wizards come
from Hacker News and Reddit
at the same time.
Is it possible to run on desktop
queries completely?
DAVE: Yes.
Very easy.
JOHAN EUPHROSINE: You just have
to wrap your API code
into Go routine and
run concurrently.
ANDREW: In essence, yeah.
But with the data store, though,
you have to be aware
that it won't necessarily
buy you a lot.
It depends what you're doing,
particularly if you're doing
transactions within
entity groups.
If you try and conduct two
transactions on same data at
same time, or even on data
that's in the same entity
group, you probably won't see
a big win over just doing it
sequentially.
Because instead of serializing
in the client, it'll just be
serializing it inside
the data store.
DAVE: He could do it probably
with a URL fetch.
You're rendering--
well, you could do fetching
your [INAUDIBLE]
from the data store at the same
time as doing a URL fetch
to that weather service because
The weather in Sydney
[INAUDIBLE].
You would be doing all that
at once, very easily.
JOHAN EUPHROSINE: I don't know
about the specifics about the
way the data store--
the smallest API layer of the
API code [INAUDIBLE].
But I know that for Python--
maybe David can confirm, but I
know that for Python when you
are doing an emergency Get on
each [INAUDIBLE], it will
actually do much better
[INAUDIBLE].
I don't know if it's doing
the same for Go.
But you have to realize that
there is that candy, that
extra level of concurrency that
sometimes is introduced
on the library layer,
so on the SDK layer.
So for me, it can look like just
an API code, but the user
will be [INAUDIBLE].
And also there is another layer
of concurrency happening
on the south side.
So when the data store back and
receive your request, it
can decide to go and
fetch [INAUDIBLE]
concurrently as well.
AMY: We had someone typing
in the chat window.
In app.yaml for Go Runtime,
we expect to find
script_goapp as the--
ANDREW: --as the main handler.
So what is the magic
behind that?
So essentially when we designed
the Go App Engine
SDK, we based it on
the Python SDK.
And so the Python SDK uses an
applet YAML file to define
[INAUDIBLE].
And in Python then, you
actually specify the
[INAUDIBLE], and then you have
a script directive that says
which Python script
is actually going
to handle this request.
But in Go, we don't run multiple
Go programs for
multiple requests.
We just run a single instance
of your Go app.
And then all of the HTTP
requests that are to be
handled by the Go app are sent
to that single app, no matter
how many handles you
have to find.
So this script calling _go_app
signifies that this is a
handler that should be
handled by the app.
And so you can't have separate
Go apps that handle different
parts of your app.
But you can just write totally
independent packages that
handle various handlers
independently.
And they can effectively be
independent programs.
But on the server side, you must
understand that they're
actually built into the
same binary, and
they're executed together.
So it's a slight departure
from the
way it works in Python.
JOHAN EUPHROSINE: I think
that you can--
you handle most of the routine
in your Go application as
opposed in Python where you
enter some of the routine at
the channel and some of the
routine in your Python
application.
It's actually a cleaner design,
because you actually
only have one place to put your
dynamic routine, whereas
in Python, you can decide to
put them in two places.
Sometimes it's confusing
for users as well.
I would like add to
what Andrew says.
You can add back ends that are
different Go apps, That?
Interact some or with your Go
application with [INAUDIBLE].
So if you need to read the same
application in space, if
you need to be deploy each part
of the Go program, you
can either use version or you
can use back end in order for
you to deploy different binary
to the same application.
ANDREW: And also if you have a
Python application and you
want to use Go to do something
that you can't do in Python,
like if you have some number
crunching or something, you
can actually deploy a Go
back-end to your Python app
and communicate between the two
using [INAUDIBLE], which
is actually a pretty powerful
combination.
You could do the same
with Java as well.
But I'd also like to
ask if you can
have multiple handlers?
And the answer is, yes, you can
have multiple handlers.
But the point that Proppy was
making is that your app
channel can basically just have
a catch-all expression in
the handler and then hand off
all of the routing requests to
the Go app itself.
So you just have your handle
clauses in the Go app handling
the [INAUDIBLE] that you want
DAVE: In fact, Proppy's example
for the tool has at
least three handlers.
JOHAN EUPHROSINE: So
any more questions?
Otherwise, I guess
we [INAUDIBLE].
DAVE: So, to an actual
binary, yeah.
JOHAN EUPHROSINE: He's
talking binary.
So Alex says that he got it like
we are combining the app
to a sort of binary, but that's
actually a binary.
DAVE: Yeah.
It's the real program.
It runs in the HC.
JOHAN EUPHROSINE: And the nice
side effect is that it's
really fast to run.
So the Go instant start-up
time is really one of the
fastest of all the App Engine
runtime, because it only needs
to read a single file in order
to start your application.
ANDREW: Yeah, in contrast to
Python, which has to actually
interpret your Python code and
fire up a Python interpreter,
or the JVM, which actually
has to load a JVM.
And so if your app sees a sudden
spike of traffic, I'd
go out and respond really,
really quickly, because it
takes hundredths of a second
to fire up a go-out.
It really is pretty
impressive.
JOHAN EUPHROSINE: Yeah, I have
a question for David.
So you know that when you start
a Go routine in App
Engine, you can only do
useful things in the
window of the request.
So if you're outside of the
request window, you can
already interact with the API.
You can still have global
channel running in the
background in your application,
but there
wouldn't be a bug to issue
an new API code, right?
DAVE: Right.
Yup.
JOHAN EUPHROSINE: I was
wondering if there is support
for [INAUDIBLE]
in the Python Java runtime,
as there was a new concept
introduced which is called
[INAUDIBLE].
That's on YouTube defined to
pull threads that span across
the request window.
But it's only for
the back end.
And I was wondering if there
is the same thing which in
planned with Go?
So we need to explain all
the things that can--
just one Go To that can interact
with API and not tied
to an HTTP request.
DAVE: So there's two modes of
operations for back ends.
There's a serving back end,
which serves requests.
You know, requests come in.
It will handle it.
It will generate a response.
And then finish up
that request.
But there's also--
I don't remember the
terminology--
lonely back ends, processing
back ends.
And in that case, what happens
is that the Go instance will
start, and the App Engine
infrastructure will say that a
request to a URL, something
like _ah/*.
Now, if the back end doesn't
return from that, then that
back end string is a long
running processing back end,
which means that you have
effectively a long running
request that can last for
minutes, hours, days, weeks.
And so during that time,
you can make API calls.
If you construct an App Engine
context from that request that
you received to _ah/*. "A," "H,"
So even if they could get
the same thing where you can
have something long running
for a long time, but
make API calls.
JOHAN EUPHROSINE: So you just
have to use the customer as
the context when you get the
warm-up and just reuse the
same context forever.
DAVE: Yeah, and not return from
that initial request.
JOHAN EUPHROSINE: OK.
ANDREW: Yeah, in effect that
becomes your main.
Like if you're running a
standalone function, then that
main-- that start handler is
just like your main function.
JOHAN EUPHROSINE: Yeah, and if
[INAUDIBLE] serving the back
end is doing IO, if this long
running back end is doing IO,
for example, like it's looking
at a channel or like looking
at API code, does that mean it
can answer incoming HTTP
requests as well?
DAVE: No.
If the back end doesn't return
from the [INAUDIBLE]
start request, it won't be
sending me more requests.
It won't be building
in that respect.
JOHAN EUPHROSINE: OK.
AMY: OK.
Well, I think we're at the top
of the hour so, as they say in
radio, so if we have no more
last minute questions, thanks
everyone very much for joining
us or for watching.
ANDREW: And thanks, Proppy,
for writing and
delivering the talk.
AMY: Thanks very much, Proppy.
See you guys next time.